what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
now if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this
if you haven't already and hit the
notification bell so youtube notifies
you whenever i upload a video
so i'm seeing this thread popping up
every now and then on reddit as well as
on places like medium
and it's all about is data science
boring
so i thought this would be an
interesting one to talk about because
for a lot of people that's probably not
going to jive with a lot of the things
you've been told about data science
everybody hypes up all the pretty
amazing visualizations you can do
the cool machine learning models that
get really really hyped up and stressed
in academic environments
and uh everybody knows harvard business
review they've called data scientists
the
sexiest job of the 21st century so
it's probably worth looking at these
perspectives about data science being
being boring and figuring out if there's
any there there
or any things that practical people can
take away from this
so we're gonna go through uh two
different reddit posts
as well as three different articles that
have been written on this topic
before we get into that some usual asks
i have for all you guys
again subscribe if you haven't already
also
smash the like button to this video
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
also i do have a link in the description
of this video to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me that way that would be
enormously appreciated
and naturally all these articles and
reddit threads that i'm going to be
going over in this video will be in the
description as well
i'm not going to go through every little
piece of them but
you can read and uh you know pick up the
pieces there on your own time
all right so this thread this was from
two months ago and it's from the user uh
xbomber88 and he says i'm five years
into my data science career and at my
third job and i just find it incredibly
boring and tedious and i'm thinking of
leaving the field and moving into a
software engineering role
just to do something new i found it
interesting in the beginning when i was
learning new things but now it seems
like pretty much
95 percent of all data science work
falls into
moving data around cleaning data build a
model by calling some outside machine
learning library
yeah that's relatively accurate so far
at least to a certain extent or trying
to explain things to business people
i imagine there are some data science
jobs out there where the work is
interesting but they seem incredibly
rare have i just gotten unlucky in the
jobs i had
or do other people who've been in the
field for a while feel the same way as
me
so right off the bat that's a fairly
comprehensive overview of what
data science does typically tend to
entail i mean oftentimes you're going to
begin from
unstructured or just generally dirty
data
and then a certain part of your job is
going to include cleaning all that up
yes you're going to have building models
in there
but it's interesting because a lot of
people really hype up that side of the
work
but then this person's acknowledging
they do that i mean they're
using machine learning libraries so i
guess they're not necessarily building
these things from scratch
but they're still commenting on how the
work is boring
and you'd actually be surprised there
are a lot of perspectives i've heard out
there that people who
literally spend all of their time in the
machine learning universe
it actually becomes the most boring
thing ever like they
you you start to go down that road for
long enough and then you
legitimately miss cleaning data believe
it or not
so that's interesting uh the top comment
here is i think a lot of it depends on
what you find entertaining
if it's more technical under the hood
cutting edge work then yes
those jobs are going to be rare and are
regularly going to go to those who are
incredibly talented and experienced
now see that's an interesting point
because just in the data science
pipeline
there's certain work like the cleaning
data and stuff which most people agree
that stuff isn't necessarily fun
but you also have the machine learning
type work which a lot of other people
really want to do
so suppose you had this dream
ideal scenario where you literally spent
all of your time
in the machine learning world again that
would for a lot of people that would
probably get boring after a while
but just just say that was your life
that could only happen at the expense of
somebody
else who's doing nothing but boring work
all the time
and i mean with the exception of like
you know interns who are in school and
they're lucky to get out and get a job
and they're happy to be doing whatever
uh people don't want to spend their
entire time doing boring work
so everybody's kind of gotta you know
pick up a piece at everything at least i
think in the overwhelming majority of
scenarios so they also say if you're
just looking for something different
what has helped me avoid that funk in my
career
has been to move industries and get more
involved on the domain knowledge side of
things
so more on that in a little bit i think
that's a super good point uh
and more on that in this other thread
because it's
very very similar so this person says
i've been a data and this is from you
slash um
i dice keyed this was two years ago they
say i've been a data scientist for
roughly
one and a half years don't really look
forward to the day-to-day work
i feel like i'm constantly
troubleshooting code searching for data
and making visualizations
spending all day staring at a computer
screen and getting frustrated with code
wears me down
um then they ask will get better as i
get more senior have more meetings
manage others
has anyone switched out of a data
scientist role for something they
enjoyed more
so again it's a fairly similar overview
of what the actual work is
i notice they don't mention anything
with uh with machine learning but they
do mention
visualizations which i'd say most people
uh really enjoy or at least
you know get in on get into data science
thinking
that's going to be a part of their work
and they really enjoy that side of it
now this person says that's the nature
of the work and certainly it can get
boring at times
a big determinant is whether you care
about the questions you're answering if
you do then it's less of a pain to
investigate them
and at least for me i have a great love
of the coding side of my work even at
times when i have
zero interest in its ultimate utility so
i think and i agree with both of these
comments
i think ultimately they're saying very
very similar things
they're both stressing that a lot of it
comes down to
your domain and maybe just more so than
your actual domain but the actual place
where you're working
because on one level just speaking
personally here
since i've been out of school my data
science work has been in healthcare
and pharma just because the notion of
just
to whatever extent possible being able
to
affect patient care and patient outcomes
that's something that really excites me
like if i hear down the road like
because of data science work i did
that it had a meaningful and tangible
effect on somebody's health guess what i
take that as a huge
satisfying win like that's one of those
things like i can go to sleep at night
if i knew
something like that happened and i feel
incredibly satisfied with myself
and same thing with the place that you
work like you have to really care about
it
like just by comparison i've known this
about myself for a long time
that i have zero interest in the
insurance industry
so it's why when in the past i've looked
for data science jobs
um i always completely ignored the
insurance industry because i know even
if i
get that job and make really good money
i'm working in an industry
i don't ultimately care about that much
and i would end up being
completely miserable and so you really
do
have to find some kind of domain and
some kind of problems to solve
that you're really interested in like if
you're going into it just for the money
um i mean that's that's that's frankly a
one-way ticket to just
burning yourself out and i mean frankly
these people
have pretty honest perspectives of what
uh the date of what data science work
entails and i'm not trying to disparage
them or make fun of them or anything
like that because
trust me i get it i've been there i've
been bored with work that i've done in
the past
but at the end of the day the work is
what the work
is there's always going to be some kind
of coding component
to data science there's always going to
be some kind of statistical fundamentals
that underlie it
um you always have to understand the
domain to a certain extent
and some jobs will probably include
machine learning
others not there's probably going to be
visualization
there's always going to be communication
with with stakeholders
i mean these are parts of of what data
science is
so if there's anything in there that
frankly you hate or you're not
interested in
data science is probably not for you
and that's and there's nothing wrong
with that but it's
it's it's another example of you just
need to know
what data science really is so that your
expectations going into it are as
aligned with reality as possible
now we've got an article here this is
from the website tdwi.org
about how do data scientists really feel
about their work
and they pretty bluntly state start this
off saying
being a data scientist isn't everything
it's cracked up to be
it has its share of boring repetitive
tasks
and so they they get into some details
here saying according to a new survey
on average data scientists spend more
than half their time
that is 53 doing stuff they don't dig
such as cleaning and organizing data for
analysis and then
a report published last this was back in
2017 i guess
yeah 2017 uh may 31st
but they found that nearly half or 45
percent of data scientists
spend huge chunks of their time cleaning
and organizing data for analysis
a task not coincidentally that a clear
majority
that is 60 percent say they enjoy least
so like i was saying earlier in that
reddit thread it really is a tragedy of
the commons type situation
that is everybody wants to have clean
data to work on
but nobody wants to actually clean the
data
so at the end of the day you're not
going to have people who spend their
entire careers
20 30 years or whatever just cleaning
data for other people to do
fun stuff it's just that's just not
going to happen
the other thing i will say like when i
read this the thought that was just
going through my head
was when people say they spend about i
mean 53
is right over half of their time doing
stuff they don't dig
that honestly doesn't sound all that bad
to me
because if you think about it like think
about your
actual real life right you probably have
to do a whole bunch of chores and things
you don't necessarily
enjoy doing like you have to do your
laundry you have to
clean the place that you live in um
maybe you enjoy cooking
some people don't enjoy that as much but
some do
you clean up after yourself after the
fact i mean not to get
super philosophical on you but you spend
a lot of your life doing boring
repetitive things
that aren't necessarily your favorite
things to do
but when you get around to doing things
that you really enjoy
there's almost something about the fact
you don't always do those things
that makes them more enjoyable actually
they
close this off by saying one last thing
data scientists really love the
cleansed qualified data they use to
train their models
and they say data scientists were given
a choice between three options
accidental deletion of their machine
code and algorithms
accidental deletion of their training
data and accident
accidental shattering of one of their
femurs that's
painful sounding so most respondents say
they'd rather
suffer loss of their algorithms than
loss of data
however 28 percent say they'd rather
break a leg than losing their than lose
their training data
so that's that's wonderful but
i remember i found myself thinking
in one of my earlier roles where this
data was just
it was a disaster it was a complete mess
and the idea at the
end was to build some kind of predictive
model
i really found myself really looking
forward to that model building side of
things and just seeing how well this
thing would predict
and sharing that with other people and
the way i looked at it was
that was going to be the reward to
myself
for that other work that i was doing and
now lastly we have this two-part
article from uh the data scientist ian
zhao
uh part one of this is actually in
towards data science and i found part
two of it in kd nuggets actually
and these articles are pretty long so
i'm not going to go through
all of them you again these these
articles are fantastic
so you can read them on your own time uh
but i'm going to overview just some big
takeaways that he has
uh ron swanson face as we go along
that's obviously an important thing
uh but this guy kind of makes the
argument that data science
can be boring sometimes and that that's
okay
so again it all comes down to making
sure your expectations
are somewhat aligned with reality he
says in short when i say data science is
boring i mean the deflating feeling when
one realizes the gap
between the romanticized expectation and
reality
um that's that's pretty fair everybody's
going to go through that feeling at some
point or another
usually probably like a year or two into
their first job
uh then they say most young data
scientists expect to spend most of the
time
tinkering with and building fancy ml
models or presenting groundbreaking
business insights with colorful
visualizations
sure these are still part of the job
yeah it's because at the end of the day
these things excite people these sell
these get people
excited to you know actually join
industry
you can't sell people on no you're going
to get data clean
but he talks in pretty
you know thorough detail here about how
he spends the majority of his time
and he's speaking from somewhat of a
leadership role here so
i mean take it for what it is but he
breaks down his time
or the time of his team rather and he
describes it as
five to ten percent of the time is spent
designing the expectation is we
implement ideas that can be featured in
famous machine learning journals
uh yada yada yada maybe even win the
next nobel prize
that would be really astounding uh in
the reality we implement things that do
the job well we take photos of some nice
whiteboard drawings that are worth
framing for
yeah at the end of the day i think most
people they'll end up going with
solutions that are a lot
simpler than what they expected going
into it i'm kind of disappointed for
their picture here that or for the gif
here
they didn't use that one you know
picture of charlie kelly with the white
board behind him from the show
uh it's always sunny in philadelphia for
those of you
who know that show but anyway he talks
about his coping mechanism is
keep talking about the crazy ideas over
drinks with friends outside of my domain
they can be brutally honest and rude do
the crazy and smart ideas as side
projects and it turns out most of the
crazy ideas don't really work
or is just marginally better than the
simple ideas exactly and i like his
point at the top about
talking about the crazy ideas over
drinks because at the end of the day
if you really enjoy the people that you
work with your job no matter what it is
you're doing whether it's data science
or anything else
you're just going to enjoy it that much
more
um he describes his fifth twenty to
seventy percent of his time
falling in the bucket of coding um
the expectation is you spend most of the
time developing and refining the ml
component
someone else will take care of the rest
um no one wants to do things you don't
want to do
or and you to keep all the goodies to
yourself like i've been saying it's a
tragedy of the commons type of situation
um he talks about later a lot of your
time is spent in qa
and debugging and fixing things um
yeah that's that's absolutely true
that's not something you necessarily
expect when you're going and do
you know any kind of job if you uh if
it's your first job
but yeah that's all over the place and
there's not a lot you can do about that
and he talks about we just need to deal
with the bad results and think of
smarter ways to build better models
that's the expectation uh in reality
out of the time we spend on qa or slash
debug
supply fixes 70 to 90 or on traditional
software issues
usually we can achieve a good enough
result fairly quickly after we build the
end-to-end model training and validation
pipeline
then we often de-prioritize modeling to
focus on system issues
yeah so what he's really getting at is
at a certain point
things like deploying a model making it
stable and scalable and all that good
stuff
that's the perspective he's coming from
here versus the expectation i think a
lot of people have that's really in the
weeds
in your python or in your r trying to
tweak and get the model's performance as
high as possible as you
feed new data into it then you spend 10
to 50 percent of your time
firefighting that is things like
external issues
like scope change upstream system
dependency and client complaints
uh internal t matters like annoying bug
that takes much longer to solve than
expected
yeah again welcome to co welcome to data
science and welcome to any kind of
capacity that involves
coding that is invariably going to
happen
um having an extra comma somewhere in a
in a select statement in a sql query
that's my personal favorite that always
gets me uh
and my own ignorance uh that's my
personal favorite and the one that i
tend to run into the most
but yeah uh he's got a really good point
here
from from a project and time management
standpoint
which is coping mechanism multiply the
timeline by two to two to five times
to leave enough buffer room if it
relates to deep technical things or
cross-team activities
yeah i i really couldn't agree with that
anymore strongly
like we really when you're inexperienced
you really
have a tendency to underestimate how
long
things take uh and it
it when you it's another one of those
instances where your expectations end up
not matching
what really happens so it's just a real
easy way not necessarily to feel bored
but just to feel extremely frustrated
so i think you get the idea from some of
these articles about just all the
practical
real world things that you run into in a
data science job
so again i think the big takeaways here
are you really have to understand
what data science truly entails
like at the end of the day again it's
going to involve coding
and coding has frustrations that go with
it
you solve these very little minuscule
type problems occasionally and fix these
bugs
which are incredibly frustrating but
again that
that is part of the job but i think it's
important
to to put things into a longer term plan
as well
like you have to think about where you
see yourself in five to ten years
and one of these reddit threads touches
on this that
a lot of people get more involved in
their domain and that ends up
that ends up being a lot more rewarding
for some people once they
really go down that road and some people
just want to manage
other people and you know manage
projects or manage other people
and that's a fine completely completely
i think
standard trajectory that comes from a
technical data science
position so it can be really helpful
just to think about where do you see
yourself in the future
and i realize i didn't go through the
the second part of the article here but
there is
one important point to highlight here
um he talks about that boring problems
are good
but then it comes down to um convincing
your boss
to buy into your ml ideas if you can
recognize and articulate
uh what the real problems are and if you
can justify
why and how machine learning can solve
it better
so that's what it comes down to at the
end of the day you are
driving change and you're convincing
people of things
and once you realize what a big part
of the data science pipeline that is and
find that part of it to be rewarding
yeah it turns out to be pretty awesome
again not
every single piece of the job is going
to be just super fun and exciting
but i think for a lot of people getting
into it as long as you do
actually know what you're getting into
you're going to find enough there that's
rewarding
and if you have a plan it's not just
going to be about the money
you'll want to do data science over an
extended period of time
so i'll leave it there that's about all
i had to say on this thread hope you
guys found this interesting that there
are some good perspectives here
and again i'll leave the links to these
articles in the
description of this video so again if
you found this video uh
interesting or entertaining again smash
the like button
and also consider sharing this video
that way i get my
uh perspectives and my videos out there
to a larger audience
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data